NICO HISCHIER STARTS OUT WITH S.
DOUGIE HAMILTON, 17 SECONDS IN.
OH, WELCOME TO
YOU SEE RIGHT THERE, TURNOVER
CREATED.
ZAON, WOULD NOT GO.
CK.
NICECE WON THE JOB.
GETS HIMSELF A GOOD SCORING
SAVE BY BERNIER, KANE, SNNECT.
DEBRINCAT GETS IT TO TOEWen: THE
SETH JONES FOR CHICAGO TO WORK
IT AHEAD.
AND THE BLACKHAWKS BREAK HUGHES
CENTER.
PUCK MANAGEMENT.
TWO FEET
BLACKHAWKS TRY TO CATCH THEM.
JONESS
HAMILTON.
LONE DEFENSEMAN ON THE POWER
PLAY.
TAKEAWAY, KIRBY DACH.
CHANCE FOR JONES.
HENG.
IT WAS ANSHOOTS.
HE SCORES!YEAR.
ONE OF THE BEST I DIDN'T CARE.
DEVILS WORK
I WANT TO SAY, THIS OUT OF THE
ZONE, WITH HELP, THE DEVILS LAN
SCORE.
THE PIPE.
IT GOES OFF THE B B WAY. BY COL.
TAKEN HERE BY IN DEEP.
KANE AT THE CIRCLE. THIS PENALT
KELLANS UP
THE REBOUND WITHZONE.
TRYING TO FORCE IT OUT IS BRATT.
TAKEN
KUBALIK.
JAROS OVER THE CHICAGO LINE. SE
THE BLACKHAWKS.
AND OFF THE UP.
HUGHES -- BACK HANDS.